because i feel like early on you were
like
on your mountains with little pump and
you know the no jumper type guys that we
would associate i wrote the soundcloud
wave out but you know at a certain point
i realized like this isn't really about
it's not really about like one
particular genre of music and really
it's not even about like
doing interviews it's really about like
building a business putting a team
together i still love doing the
interviews but i also just like at a
certain point like a lot of this [ __ ]
this just seems kind of silly like you
know i'm like standing on stage like a
16 year old kid and he's chanting [ __ ] j
cole to the audience and it's like i'm
getting blamed for it because i'm the
only person who's 30 in the room
and uh yeah i mean so those like
cert i was i was going to say because
there there was like a a moment where
you know
you were heavily associated with a lot
of stuff that would happen that you
really didn't have anything to do with
so did you kind of
was there like a moment where you were
like you know what i got to kind of step
back a bit from like
being in the mix too much with some of
these kids i mean honestly yeah
definitely like that [ __ ] got old really
quick especially when everybody started
dying from drug overdoses and [ __ ] was
like oh like like you know when i look
at like how i was with pump and purp
where i was kicking it with them
drinking lean popping pills and [ __ ] and
then by the time juice world rolls
around it's like i had a friendship with
juice world
i would go to the studio with him it was
cool but then i started to like be kind
of uncomfortable with like this dude's
getting [ __ ] up and this [ __ ] ain't
really like fun or cool i don't feel
like i'm responsible like being around
this kind of stuff because at that point
i wasn't partying i just stopped at one
point like i was drinking doing coke
doing pills all this [ __ ] i just stopped
like a few years ago and just all that
[ __ ] kind of just stopped seeming fun to
me you know so like where i'm at in my
life like i just don't want to like see
teenagers popping pills in front of me
especially if you're not like it's like
it's like you're going you know the
studio sessions are they could be very
uh oh yeah debaucherous yeah so you're
in the studio and you're you're sober
you're not participating in this [ __ ]
do you feel like with the juice world
[ __ ] like
because i do remember you being in the
studio with him all the time you had a
great relationship with him a couple
times but yeah did you feel like um
like man if i'm if i keep coming around
this [ __ ] like i'm kind of participating
in the negligence yeah and it just
stopped being me like i stopped getting
[ __ ] up so all of a sudden i'm
starting to see [ __ ] clearly which is
like oh like you know i i've been in the
studio with rappers where i've seen them
like really like needing lean like mad
yelling at their friends like upset
about not having lean and then i think
about it like yo like two years ago this
[ __ ] seemed cute to me like i thought
the the lean [ __ ] was all well and good
you know and it's like and i'm saying
this a.d is probably thinking this that
he saw me drink lane the other day but
very very rare occasion that way
[ __ ] just don't seem cute after a
certain point you know and for me it's
like at a certain point you know i had a
[ __ ] kid and you know i'm like
serious about my business i wake up at
seven in the morning every day i'm not
he'll tell you that you can't get me to
leave the house past midnight pretty
much at this point in my life and you've
asked for his phone after eight um